joining me now Congressman Byron
Donald's member of the House oversight
committee and Tim parlor he is a former
attorney for president Trump thank you
both for being here Congressman what did
these stories tell you about the threat
to democracy and why do we hear so
little about this Brazen election
tampering well first the stories tell me
it confirms what we already know it's
what Democrats do before every election
before every election they go into court
and they sue constantly trying to get
weakening of election laws or just
completely complete removal of election
procedures on many different areas this
is what happened before the 2020
election they were in court everywhere
trying to get things like these
dropboxes in every in every municipality
in the country saying that it was too
hard to vote because of covid-19 people
needed to drop it in a receptacle
outside the building that was a joke and
a lie it is not needed but they do this
every single time because they want to
weaken the the the infrastructure of
voting they want to weaken the controls
around voting they want to make it easy
for these outside groups to drop ballots
all over the place and to subvert the
will of the voters who actually take
their time to do their work these
outside groups need to go these ballot
harvesting operations need to go but
this is part and parcel of what the
Democrats do these stories now
demonstrate what we've already have
known the reason why nobody knows about
it is cuz big media is not going to
cover this they only to talk about
January 6th that's all I was stunned
when I came across these stories and I'd
heard nothing of them anywhere nowhere
Tim even CNN's legal analyst knows how
silly this main ballot situation is
trying to strip Trump from the ballot
watch this if you look at the hearing
and she details this in the in the
ruling they heard from one fact witness
a law professor she based her ruling on
a lot of documents but also YouTube
clips news reports things that would
never pass the bar in in normal Court
Tam is there any legal justification for
removing Trump from the ballot and
invoking the 14th Amendment to do so I
mean does it even apply I read the 14th
Amendment today his office the
presidency doesn't seem to be stipulated
there when they mention Congress people
and Senators those offices are
explicated not the
president well I mean I think that this
is something that Congress has already
codified you know it's in Title 18 us
code for a criminal code section on
Insurrection it's defined it has its
sentence up to 10 years in prison and
permanently being barred from holding
public office that is the proper
procedure you have to indict somebody
you have to try them and convict them
and that's how you remove them from the
ballot and what's important to remember
here is that multiple grand juries in
sitting in Washington DC hearing the
direct evidence not just some law
professor they've all declined to bring
this charge even in the uh in the
oathkeepers case they decided to go one
level below that for the seditious
conspiracy and declined to actually
bring an Insurrection charge so nobody's
been charged with an Insurrection
nobody's been convicted of an
Insurrection so saying that somebody
participated in it and removing them
from the ballot really does go against
the rule of law yeah an attorney wrote
in Maine today none of what has
transpired or is upcoming is
anti-democratic in our system of
constitutional government or unlawful
interference with the election or the
right to vote this is the process by
which the rule of law is actualized in
our system of government Congressman
very quickly how is taking off removing
a leading candidate from a major
political party not
anti-democratic it it's very
anti-democratic anybody that says
otherwise is a fool and is lying to the
American people I want to talk to
Democrat voters for a moment you rank
and file Democrat voters you work hard
you live life you're not really
political you have people in your party
who are radicals who are anti-democratic
they don't believe in the will of the
people they don't believe in votes in
The Ballot Box legitimate ones they
don't even believe in the rule of law
and actually following the rule of law
they only care about their agenda you
got to stop voting for these people
because they are the ones who are
destroying America's Republic they are
the ones who are threats to our
democracy Congressman Tim thank you we
will leave it there happy New Year hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere
else